[Musique]
je suis les ânes la vraie georges suis
comédienne je suis un heureux mélange
entre marc labrèche fabienne d'or mais
de parents mon grand père paternel et
alliés dans la brèche ma grand mère
maternelle et michel la brèche à rouge
c'est très désolant des fois de
remarquer que j'ai pas de personnalité
jeu je peux voir des sketches que j'ai
faite piges je vois ce qu'il ya un petit
2 secondes où ces thèmes afrique et
c'est même pas une volonté de ma part
mais en plus que physiquement bon je lui
ressemble quand même beaucoup
puis on s'entend que dans certains
sketchs actionnaire je ne vois pas
nécessairement juste des femmes ou des
femmes avec des périodes courtes qui
font en sorte que b colline je voyais
complètement mon père il y avait un
angle une affaire et je de france une
supercoupe d'un logement sortir et pour
la gagne
[Musique]
ma mère le fantôme de la famille
personne ne sait qui s'était dame très
artistique aussi internes touche à tout
elle a travaillé très jeune dans des
théâtres elle a été régisseur elle était
éclairagiste mais donne le goût de de ce
culte iv à plusieurs formes d'art et m'a
vraiment donné goût de leur visuel d'une
l'oeuvre qui est extérieur à soi
ce que j'ai fait quand même longtemps
pour moi la famille c'est un havre de
paix est un sanctuaire de joie de
plaisir et d'encouragement du belge près
pas me passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]